Here's the plan for this lesson.
We'll start by outlining this general
design technique of dynamic programming.
Then we'll see three examples
in the sequence alignment or
edit distance problem.
This is also a very minor
generalization of the longest
common subsequence problem.
Also in the chain matrix
multiplication problem.
Where we're given a sequence
of matrices to multiply and
we want to place the parentheses in
the right order to do it efficiently.
And the all-pairs shortest
paths problems for the graph.
Good references for these topics
are Dasgupta, Papadimitriou, and
Vazirani, their book on Algorithms.
And the classic Cormen,
Leiserson, Rivest,
Stein, Introduction to Algorithms.